- So what's the genesis
of this or whatever,
how'd you find it?
- I used to do portraits,
I'm a photographer. I did these portraits
down in Skid Row, which is
kind of like LA's tenderloin,
but much, much bigger.
And there was this one
heroin addict, prostitute,
that I got to know, and Canon came out
with these cameras that did
video. And I'm like, yo,
I got this new camera.
Let's do a little video.
Tell me your life story. And she did.
And it was the most
heartbreaking fucking thing
I ever heard. And I'm
like, Jesus fucking Christ.
I cried. She cried. The whole thing was-
- [Henry] There's some
fucked up shit out here.
- [Mark] So I did, I did a few more.
And then I learned very
quickly, like Jesus Christ.
There's a lot of stories
that are similar to this.
So then I started doing,
I've done 1700 of them now.
- Wow.
- Yeah.
Mostly down in LA.
I just, I just got up here and
started doing them yesterday
and they're, they're heartbreaking.
I had a YouTube channel
that- they just took off
after I started posting all this stuff.
I got pimps, and prostitutes, and escorts,
and drug addicts, and drug dealers
and gang members, and
everything that you imagine
- Shmucks like me that
are none of those things
but still down here, I uh-
I don't have a particularly
heartbreaking story,
- [Mark] No, it doesn't have to be.
- but I have heard a lot of
the heartbreaking stories
and some of them were pretty compelling.
It's hard to not want to root
for these people or whatever.
I'm not a particularly big
you must have the expression,
Captain Save-A-Hoe,
that isn't me. Although I think
a lot of people portray me that way.
- [Mark] What do they say? Captain what?
- Captain Save-A-Hoe
- [Mark] Oh, I see.
- Like yeah, I come in
here and get you clean,
rescue you from all that.
That's never been my goal.
But it's hard not to at least
want to break more, you know-
I'll at least be nice. I'm not
going to treat you like shit.
- [Mark] I fall for some of that too.
- Yeah. It's... yeah. Some
of the stories are tough.
Yeah. Yeah.
- [Mark] Alright. Henry,
where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Henry] Outside Philadelphia, suburbs.
- [Mark] And you grew up with
both your parents? As a kid?
- [Henry] Yeah. My dad
was on his third marriage.
He was pretty old. So he
died when I was probably 17,
senior year of high
school. And my mom died
a couple of years after
that, but uh teenager years
and younger, yeah, very normal family.
- [Mark] Good childhood?
- Yeah. Yeah. Parents loved each other
as far as I know, didn't fight
and I know they both loved me.
- [Mark] That's great.
And then after school,
you went to college?
- Yup.
- [Mark] Where'd you go?
- University of Michigan.
- [Mark] Great school.
- Yeah. I had a lot of
fun. Syracuse for a year,
and University of Michigan after that,
and came to California
literally the day I graduated.
- [Mark] And what'd you do for work?
- First did some event,
sports event promotions,
but then got into the
high-tech gig out here
in San Francisco, worked
for some of the really big,
really big companies, Cisco
and Oracle, people like that.
- [Mark] And you've been married before?
- Yeah. Once. Divorce, going through
the divorce process.
It's basically over now,
separated already. Divorced Penny.
- [Mark] And how old are you?
- 51.
- [Mark] 51. And you have kids?
- Two, that are 12 years-old. Twins.
- [Mark] Okay. And so, you're basically
on good terms with your family.
You've had no terrible childhood,
nothing crazy to report.
- Yeah. And I, I mean, not
orphan so much, but loss
of my parents, you know,
in my college years,
good terms with my family, for sure...
- [Mark] But you lost your parents, how?
- Both terminal illnesses, one was cancer,
and one was very similar to Parkinson's,
- [Mark] I'm sorry.
- but you know, I was 17.
I got to 19 when they died.
But good terms with the
rest of my family for sure
until really the last couple of years
when I sort of- the marriage was
on its way to getting,
you know, having trouble.
And I kind of, what's
the right word, sort of-
momentum brought me down
to downtown San Francisco
and that's turned out to be,
you know a little bit of
alienating or whatever.
- [Mark] So you like to have fun
with some of the girls down here?
- Yeah, yeah.
At least I thought it
was going to be, yeah.
It's the idea of having fun,
being on my own, you know, a little bit
and try to have fun and get high.
- [Mark] Right. Well, I
mean, how did this start?
I mean, 'cause, 'cause did it start
with the girls in the
tenderloin or were there others?
- No, I think- no there's a little bit
before the last, I've been
sort of in and out of here.
Well, steadily more and
more here for the last
probably three years named before.
But prior to that, a little bit of escort,
a medium amount of escort dabbling
that true escorts, like, you know,
- [Mark] The more expensive.
- Yeah, yeah.
Website ads and clear, you know
that's their real source
of income, full time.
- [Mark] And what do those girls cost you?
- I don't ever think I spent more
than maybe 800 bucks an hour.
There may have been a
couple times like an hour
and a half for, you know,
12 or 14 or something,
but never- I didn't do
super, super high end,
but you know, 500 bucks and
up, you know, encounters.
- [Mark] Yeah. And then in the tenderloin,
it's much cheaper, right?
- Quite a bit. I don't know really,
but I have a sense of some of it.
I- There's a point, I
used to actually think
that there was a point
at a couple of hundred
bucks an hour, that if
you went below that,
you were starting to get
into sketchy risk of,
you know, God knows what else,
you know, drugs, robbery, and you know,
whatever flake outs and scams.
There's still that line somewhere.
I don't know exactly where it is, but yeah
there's girls doing double
digit dates with people here
much more often than there
probably ought to be.
Not all.
- [Mark] Have you ever
been arrested before?
- I have. Yeah. But not for any of the-
I have two drug possession charges
that were really just
cited, but I've got a couple
of missed court dates that turned
into warrants that have
gotten me arrested.
I've never been like kept in jail.
I bailed out each time
but I've been arrested.
There's three times
on fitness court dates, like kind
of minor stuff compared to
the real hood down here.
But that's kinda, I don't, I don't really
consider myself in the "right place" here.
- [Mark] Right. Drugs are a
part of the picture for you?
Or they were?
- Yeah, or they were in a
much bigger way, but yeah.
That's been a part of my life
for the last bunch of years.
- [Mark] What drug are you dabbling in?
- I used to be a big, big Coke fiend,
but only in spots. I had a
problem with it for about,
I guess, a few years, a handful of years,
when I, right around, when I got married
and I probably for, I
don't know, a few years.
But I was clean off, at least off that,
no hard drugs really, besides pot
and occasional, you know,
stuff at music events
or whatever, but I didn't do
any Coke for about nine years.
And then all of a sudden tried it once
and we kind of didn't
stop for, for a few years
after that I stopped doing
powder Coke awhile ago
and started smoking it instead,
but that didn't prevent-
it didn't make things any better.
But, and then some other
stuff, I definitely smoke a lot
of pot along the way and
dabbled a little bit in meth.
- [Mark] So you're still using today?
- I can't say that I'm not, but I'm
at the end of a run
that I'm glad is ending.
- [Mark] Yeah, so back back to the ladies,
is it something that started
when you were married?
- Yeah, I had a sort of a,
even before I was married,
just sort of a curious
side of just some, you know
not just necessarily
fantasy stuff, but just
I think it's cool. I
have a pretty open sexual
like approach to sexuality, whatever.
I don't have any issue like
morally with escorting.
I think it's cool. And you can meet
some really interesting
people without any of the
other friction and you know,
whatever kind of real
life dramas around it.
So I did some of it just
to see what was out there.
There was a twist that I
kind of got into along,
I did a lot of stuff like phone sex lines
and stuff too, which got into
like Dom/Sub type of dynamic.
And when I moved to San Francisco,
I found out that there were a couple
of places here that are like
organized homes with girls
that'll do- women- that'll do, you know
sort of fantasy exploration stuff, no sex,
but everything up to it.
And so I dabbled in that a lot.
I kind of got hooked on
that for a little while
and then, you know, escorts
on that side of that too,
and it was all kind of secret.
I didn't have a problem
with having that interest,
but it didn't really fit my like, you know
Fortune 500 country club, kind of life.
So I just didn't really
bother telling very many
people about it and it was kind of my own,
not really a secret, but kind of.
So there was, yeah, there
was a little bit of that
and it was not my wife's,
it didn't fit her approach.
I mean, like I would be a swinger,
if I'd met the right kind of female,
but I think I would anyway,
but that was definitely
not her thing at all.
So I kind of had this moral decision about
just because it's totally not her thing.
Does that mean I'm not
allowed to explore it too?
And I guess at some level I decided
that it was okay to
still have, I don't know,
I make a pretty big distinction
in my head, and by the way
this is not, this is not
opinion that is shared
by the woman I'm getting divorced from.
But I think there's a big distinction
between going to see an
escort and having an affair
with someone that you
like mutually agree to
have a relationship with. In the end,
they're both, you know
deceptive and whatever,
but I really do, I feel
differently about both of them.
And so I just kind of went with it.
I deserved to, you know
have fun with what I am interested in
as long as it wasn't hurting anybody.
And that's what I thought was the case.
- [Mark] And you practice
safe sex and all that?
So you're not-
- Yeah, always, I've never really run into
any pressure from escorts.
Like, I don't know, I never really,
honestly, as naive as it sounds,
I never really knew that like
no condom sex was really that big of a,
of a friction or whatever.
That's a terrible pun, isn't it? Sorry.
But I, being here now,
I hear a lot of stories
about how prevalent that is
- I think it's pretty common.
- and the tricks, and shenanigans,
and how many guys dangle more money,
or more promises or
more, whatever, bullshit
about if I can do this, if I can do that.
And it sounds like it's a much more
pervasive problem than
I ever really expected.
And it surprises me. I just don't.
If, if some girls do it, I know some do.
The girls that do it, the
guys find those girls,
and now it's just, you
know, they tell two friends,
and they tell two friends.
And the next thing you know,
it just seems so risky.
I don't understand it,
but I, my preference, I guess
for a lot of it was always
the sort of GFE type dynamic
from red book days, whatever
that like oral isn't,
but sex is always safe and it's,
I don't know, seems "fine."
I don't know why that isn't a thing, but.
- [Mark] Did you find
doing this gets in the way
of a possible romantic relationship,
a real relationship with
a girl that's not a pro?
- [Henry] No. Well, I mean,
let me say it this way,
this lifestyle, kind of
tenderloin, drugs and sex,
and all kinds of, part of one story,
that's a pretty hard lifestyle to maintain
because keeping a job while you're not
really on your A-game, inherently,
isn't very sustainable.
But if you were managing or if you were a
functioning addict,
it's possible, I guess,
but it's not very, it's
not very realistic.
The girls part I put
differently, you know, being
in a real relationship and still
seeing escorts on the side,
I think a lot of the women
I know have tricks that are
or whatever, you know, frequent clients,
or whatever, that are either married
or have real relationships,
that part's doable.
Add all the drugs, and flakiness,
and time management challenges,
and all that sort of stuff to that.
And it's not going to
be not going to be easy.
- [Mark] Yeah, it's a
complicated question, isn't it?
- [Henry] Yeah. And it's just, you know
it's sort of know your
audience, if you're fishing
in a pond full of flaky, selfish,
you know, craving
junkies, which frankly is
what a lot of people here are, you gotta,
you know, you gotta, filter your,
or lower, your expectations.
- [Mark] So your view of
these girls that do this
is they're just providing a service
and it's all cool with you, right?
- So it's an experience, I think,
not just the service. I think
I'm very escort friendly,
or whatever, I don't have any issues
with women that, that do- well.
There's a huge distinction in my head
between women who do
this because they want to
or are okay with it, see
the financial benefits.
I have lots of friends who have jobs
they hate but they make
enough money to justify it.
If that's you who are,
I'm totally okay with it.
I know there's an awful lot of people
that don't get here by that path
and I'm not okay- I mean, trafficking
and some of the- I'm not
even gonna get into that.
There's definitely cases
here that are not okay.
But as a concept, escorting, you know,
charging people to spend
time providing an experience,
absolutely okay with it.
And I don't think women who have sex
as a career makes them, I just,
I don't judge on that level at all.
I'm much more sympathetic
to trying to help people,
you know, feel good
about what they're doing.
It's certainly, that's why it's around.
'Cause it makes guys feel good too.
And what's the, at the end of the day
what's really so bad about that?
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Yeah. I don't, I don't judge like that,
but rip people off, scam
people, break into cars,
steal people's stuff,
whole different story.
- [Mark] What's the
craziest story you've seen
in your experiences
doing this kind of stuff?
- I uh, the, what I would call the
reliable, higher tier
price range escorting,
I really never had any kind of surprises.
The one, I guess it
jumps to my head first,
a very money driven, selfish, and
you know, acts accordingly, kind of woman,
who I met early in my days down here.
And I said, she said she typically tries
to get it, you know 250 bucks an hour
for her and her engagements,
which turned out
to be more than I think
it was actually real.
I said something about
"Yoli, the kind of person
you seem to be, you really,
if you put a website together,
took a few pictures, you
really could jump into
the four or 500 bucks
an hour tier, you know,
pretty much right away." I didn't know
how many other personality facets she had,
but she decided on the spot that
that made her a 500 dollar an hour escort.
And I think the best, the weirdest story,
came one night, she had plans
to come over and see me.
Showed up something like
five and a half hours late
and was absolutely hammered on,
I don't even know what, way more messed up
than normal. Belligerently, just blabbing
all over the place, probably was there
for a couple of hours
before I had to leave
and go home in the morning, I was still
like sort of separated
from my family at the time
and going home in the morning
to help the kids get up and go to school.
And it was just a total wash out.
So I didn't really, you know, sort of
it just was, I wiped it out.
In revenge, first of all, she
came out of that saying
you owe me, you know,
$1,000 for two 500 hours,
two hours, $500 an hour,
which is the debate we had
for months, and months, and months,
but also, she got really mad at me
and had a whole bunch of
people come over to the hotel.
We'd randomly gotten
upgraded, for no reason,
into a suite. They wiped out the mini bar.
They ordered all the porn movies
they could possibly
find. And then wouldn't
check out the next day. So I ended up
with an $1,800 hotel bill,
plus this expectation
that I suddenly owed them a thousand bucks
for a completely horrible
two hour experience.
All 'cause she was pissed that
she wasn't really a 500
dollar an hour hooker,
escort, sorry. It was a mess.
- [Mark] That goes with
the territory, I think.
- Yeah. A little bit.
That's a little extreme, but yeah.
Yeah, those aren't, I'm
sure I wasn't the first one.
- [Mark] Yeah. Well
Henry, thank you so much
for being so honest and
sharing your stories.
- Sure. No problem at all.
- [Mark] Good luck with uh-
- Yeah, I hope somebody
somewhere learns from this.
- [Mark] I'll bet you
there's a lot of guys
that are doing this
kind of stuff and just,
it's good to know that
there's others out there and-
- Yeah. Just, just be smart.
- They're not crazy.
- [Henry] You get what you pay for,
is the message I say to myself a lot.
- [Mark] Absolutely. All
right. Thank you so much.
- Sure.